Lets see if we can give ourselves a little bit
of practice converting between radians and degrees
and degrees and radians.
And just as a review lets just remind ourselves the relationship
and I always do this before I have to convert between the two.
If I do one revolution of a circle how many radians is that going to be?
Well we know one revolution of a circle is (2)(pi) radians
and how many degrees is that if I do one revolution around a circle?
Well we know that is 360 degrees.....
I can either write it with the little degree symbol like that or I can write it just like that.
And this is really enough information for us to think about
how to convert between radians and degrees
if we want to simplify this a little bit we can divide both sides
by 2.
And you can have (pi) radians are equal to 180 degrees
or another way to think about it
going halfway around a circle in radians is (pi) radians.
The arc that subtends that angle is (pi) radiusssses
and that's also 180 degrees.
And if you wanna really think about, well how many degrees are there per radian
you can divide both sides of this by (pi).
So if you divide both sides of this by (pi),
you would get one radian
it would have to go from plural to singular
one radian is equal to 180/pi degrees.
So all I did is I divided both sides by (pi)
and if you wanted to figure out how many radians
are there per degree you can divide both sides by 180.
So you would get pi/180 radians
is equal to 1 degree.
So this is....now I think we are ready to start converting.
So lets convert 30 degrees....to radians.
So lets think about it.
I'm going to write it out and actually this might remind you of unit analysis
that you might do when you first did unit conversion
but it also works out here.
So if I were to write 30 degrees
and this is how my brain likes to work with it
I like to write out the word degrees.
Well I wanna convert to radians so I really want to figure out
how many radians are there per degree?
So let me write this down. I wanna figure out how many radians do we have per degree?
And I haven't filled out how many that is
but we see the units will cancel out
if we have degrees times radians/degree
the degrees will cancel out and I'll be just left with radians.
If I multiply the number of degrees I have times the number of radians per degree
we're gonna get radians.
And hopefully that makes intuitive sense as well.
And here we just have to think about
well if I have...think of it this way, if I have
pi radians how many degrees is that?
Well that's 180 degrees, comes straight out of this right over here
pi radians for every 180 degrees or pi/180 radians/degree.
This is going to get us to...we're going to get 30 times pi/180
30 times pi/180
which will simplify to
30/180 is 1/6
so this is equal to pi/6
let me write the units out
this is 30 radians which is equal to pi/6 radians.
Now lets go the other way
lets think about if we have pi/3 radians
and I wanna convert that to degrees.
So what am I going to get if I convert that to degrees?
Well here we're gonna want to figure out
how many degrees are there per radian?
One way to think about it is
think about the pi and the 180
for every 180 degrees you have pi radians.
180 degrees/pi radians
these are essentially the equivalent thing
essentially you're just multiplying this quantity by 1
but you're changing the units
the radians cancel out and then the pi's cancel out
and you're left with 180/3 degrees
180/3 is 60 and we can either write out the word degrees or you can write degrees
just like that.
Now lets think about 45 degrees.
So what about 45 degrees?
And I'll write it like that just so you can figure it out with that notation as well.
How many radians will this be equal to?
Well once again we're gonna want to think about how many radians do we have per degree?
So we're going to multiply this times
well we know we have pi radians
for every 180 degrees
or we can even write it this way
pi radians for every 180 degrees.
And here this might be a little less intuitive
the degrees cancel out and that's why I usually like to
write out the word
and you're left with 45 pi/180 radians.
Actually let me write this with the words written out
for me that's more intuitive when I'm thinking about it
in terms of using the notation.
So 45 degrees times, we have pi radians for every 180 degrees.
So we are left with when you multiply
45 times pi over 180
the degrees have canceled out and you're just left with
radians.
Which is equal to what?
45 is half of 90 which is half of 180 so this is 1/4
this is equal to pi over 4 radians.
Lets do 1 more over here.
So lets say that we had negative pi/2 radians.
What's that going to be in degrees?
Well once again we have to figure out
how many degrees
are each of these radians.
We know that there 180 degrees
for every pi radians
so we're gonna get
the radians cancel out
the pi's cancel out
and so you have
-180/2
this is -90 degrees
or we can write it as -90 degrees.
Anyway hopefully you found that helpful
and I'll do a couple more example problems here
because the more example for this
the better and hopefully it will become
a little bit intuitive